Brandon with the black piece is
definitely a very difficult game and it
felt like you were quite uncomfortable
with your position you were spending a
lot of time the position was quite
uncomfortable tell us a bit about your
experience with this game yeah no so
I figured during this game I was just
going to try to sleep well not prepare
too much and it's kind of funny because
I looked at this line and like I looked
at every move order of like rookie one
ipd2 H3 and as I was walking into the
game I realized what if white goes
rookie just in my head I was walking the
guy was like What if white goes rookie
won
um in H3 without 92. how am I supposed
to play this because
so the thing for black normally is like
um so they have Ricky Wayne she's white
wants to play a quick D4 and not a lot
of Bishop G4 okay and so if I play
Something Like H takes then D4 is
probably pretty strong here and okay I
can go B5 and transpose some other line
but that's not really what I want
um
and yeah or I can start with B5 Bishop
C2 but now it's not really clear what I
do because again wait is maybe this is
what I should have done in Cisco Bishop
B7 here and it kind of transposes to
some somewhat somewhat like something
that I know
um but I kind of figured like okay
Bishop f8 can't be the wrong move like
Bishop G5 H6 Bishop H4 I mean I figured
worst case like I can play like Bishop
B7 here it's probably not a big deal I
got to this position and I realized I'm
actually in pretty big trouble here
because
like if I go Bishop B7 I feel like I'm
kind of down the tempo on normal Italian
lines right
um and no maybe he can reshuffle go
Bishop g3p4 yeah and if I go G5 like
like I played I mean I figured it's
probably a bit unsound but I thought it
would be an interesting try at least
um but then yeah I mean I played this
terribly after Knight D2
um B5 Bishop C2 I think maybe instead of
yeah Bishop B7 was a terrible move and
if even after 9 F1 I was considering
Bishop back to ca it was such a bad move
um I think like sort of similar to what
I did in the game like with 97 Knight G6
everything yeah
of course and yeah I mean I think I sort
of hallucinated tell us why why is the
bishop much better on C8 than on B7 yeah
so I mean Bishop B7 is only useful if
I'm going to be preparing D5 so I kind
of hallucinated some some D5 thing but
it's it's all pretty bad I think um
because whenever whenever I go D5 you
just go like 93 Queen two and kind of
just leave it there yeah um and yeah
like with the bishop on C if he goes
like I can play quick 97 Bishop E6 and I
think maybe this isn't so bad for black
okay I see the computer I'm still worse
but it's kind of like playable
yeah so
Bishop p7 yeah and the issue with this
with an f-197 is that like after 93
instead of Knight G6 go back like I mean
I just completely underestimated that H4
was gonna crash me in the king so I
thought I'd have time for some C5 C4
counter replay but I I just as soon as I
got here I realized like I'm in pretty
serious trouble so at this point I'm
kind of trying to find all the only move
to stay in the game every move yeah
um and
I think kind of luckily there's no like
direct way for white to put me away
after Knight G6 I mean so yeah five
nights exactly so after 95 97 I figured
like the principled way for white to
play to take the bishop like you did so
you take it and then go something like
B4 is what I expected B4 yeah just to
stop C5 and then go A4 A4 right should
be much better here and but I can kind
of like sense he's a little bit shaky in
its first round so I kind of tried to
play logical trick I was like shaking my
head a lot on purpose and I was trying
to like beat him to to go H4 and kind of
you know like try to put me away here
because my position looks terrible
um it was not really experience it moves
right yeah I figured I mean I spent all
my time and I figured it's my only
chance because if he goes b4a for
something normal like I I'm you don't
have any trouble yeah so I tried to beat
him to go H4 he didn't like I played
nitro6 pretty quickly I I okay
apparently it works but I was just
trying to to complicate the game I had
no idea this was actually any good or
not yeah um and I think what he did in
the game I think what he was counting on
was after Rook h8 Bishop B3 Rook H5 I
think what he missed was Knight takes F7
um and I went through another quiz
Summer Queen D7 yeah so let's say queen
E7 Queen D2
yeah now I can go D5
oh not through config no okay uh Knight
G5
and this is a total mess but after you
get Rook h8 okay see the computer
actually backs it up kf1
exactly not something like Queen D7
let's say and White's up two pawns now
but it's actually kind of difficult to
find a move yeah because of F3 I can
take on e4
and that's nice yeah and I didn't see
any better than a draw for him yeah so I
think he sort of thought like
right I think he sort of thought that
he's getting that fun and getting his
Knight back and didn't I know he
underestimated by counter play here did
you chat with him afterwards did he
calculate any of these or after a game
with this I don't think he would be in
the mood to talk I don't think I would
be either no like I I think like a lot
of it was just was just nerves and we
both played pretty terribly for being
honest but um I I know what happens
first round of the tournament and it was
such a complicated position it's it's
really tough to evaluate these things
especially with lowen when you're low on
time but he also played for like a full
month before this in Europe and you were
mentioning that and you are mentioning
the first round and being shaky having
some rust on your shoulders do you feel
that that month in Europe helped you
start I wouldn't necessarily rest I just
um just I mean it's a pretty serious
event playing the first round of
something like this it's kind of a
different experience especially because
I haven't played a one game a day
tournament a long time in a while I
don't think he has either like we both
came from the world up and a few days
ago so I think it's hard to adjust like
that tournament was with 30 delay the
time control so it's pretty hard to
adjust from like a fast-paced tournament
where you kind of just have to trust
your instincts to like something super
serious
um I definitely feel like my my
tournament Spirit was a good experience
and it did help me like put things
together better
um but yeah like at the same time like
most of my games in Europe I was playing
on an hour or two of sleep and just sort
of I don't know having fun with it I
didn't I could have done a lot better
and like I think that um
like for me at least tournaments like
this motivate me to take it more
seriously and actually you know like
take my preparation my sleep and my
routine pretty seriously during the
event so I don't know I think different
people have different styles and do
better in different events I know some
people hate one game a day some people
hate the more serious events but I think
for me it's what I need to motivate me
to be more disciplined you're also
coming into this event as the rating
favorite does that put any extra
additional pressure on you well I'm not
sure what rating they're using for me to
be reading educational I think I think
Mr outrates Me by quite a bit but no I
wouldn't say it has any extra pressure I
mean this is my last year it feels weird
being the oldest because it's funny like
when I was like 14 or something playing
my first event here I was like okay I
have four years left before I'm too old
I'm sure I'll win one of them and I
didn't even come close in any of them so
you know it I wouldn't say that's extra
pressure but I would say like it is it
does feel like now is like my shot so
in some sense I guess in some sense it's
a good thing in some sense it's a bad
thing guys any questions yeah Brandon
first of all congratulations very nice I
want you to bring you to the game to the
game position when you played the move
Rook takes G2 for our audience could you
just tell us how far did you calculate
the Rook sacrifice variation well which
you played in the game
okay so yeah instead of what takes G2 I
kind of figured that like I could play
something like rook d8 and probably have
a good position but being so low on time
and like the position's still messy with
no like clear threat I figured it's
probably better to go for something
risky and and just and see how it goes
and that F4 came F1 Queen H2 yet so what
I saw is okay you can't move this work
off the e-file because then he takes D4
so basically there's rookie three and
rookie four
um after rookie four well okay so again
talking about first round nerves and
rest like in my head I had Queen G2
Knight G3 and then I like my hand
playing Knight G3 without realizing and
I tried to not like hesitate to make him
not inspect anything and the thing is
after G3 he did take a minute so I like
Bishop HD3 I should probably be winning
for White Queen takes D2 Bishop takes F4
I mean the game goes on I can take on B2
and have some Bishop F5 maybe but it's
kind of hard to believe this could
actually work for black
um but I was just sitting there trying
not to panic for the whole minute he was
thinking realizing that I meant to go
Queen G2 first just all
um so so from this yeah so for this
rookie for that I did see what I had and
then so the other options were E3
and here honestly like I didn't really
calculate much but I saw there were a
bunch of like Slinky ideas like there's
a lot of like for example Queen G2
um key one Knight G3
King D1
I think that F1 for example
your queen E1
and I don't know like at some point I
thought I could play some quiet maybe if
I don't even know what maybe just Bishop
F5 yeah Bishop F5 and I saw up to here
and I figured you know we're both low on
time like if we get here then it looks
like I don't know a nightmare to play
with white and I thought it was a good
practical decision and it did work out
but
I'm not quite sure what is going on here
like my guess is computer would say all
zeros or something that just always what
happens but
probably Rick d8 was was a better move
um and I figured during the game that
that made more sense but I don't know I
kind of I I already went this far to
attack and may as well try to take you
to and see how it goes and yeah I think
like a big problem for me lately has
been not trusting myself trusting my
intuition
um in a lot of positions where I feel
like I want that like like I gotta get
position and then I'm not trusting
myself to find like the the Breakthrough
and I figured you know what we're
already here amazing this is uh three
people zeros but yeah
yeah
it's interesting I didn't even consider
a rookie too it just felt wrong to me
but
yeah it's just that's the funny aspect
of it so what happens if Queen G2 and
Knight she's three I'm just curious
yeah Knight G3
Queen E3 only
[Music]
some crazies okay this I didn't see at
all no it makes sense it makes sense but
yeah like it it I figured you probably
had some some defense but I think with
long time it's it's very difficult
impossible yeah
yeah no I was so sorry Brandon I didn't
want to I I didn't want to point out
that you're completely bluffing out
people and Brilliant well yeah sir I
think you've commented enough of my
games to know that I'm always blocked
Brandon I'm curious when was the moment
when you figured out like you are
winning because you were really low on
time and like the move it takes D4 was
that the moment when move 40 you made
and you were like okay I'm winning or
was it still unclear because it was a
crazy game very complicated game at the
end well I mean when you play rookie
four I was pretty confident I was
winning but besides the scare with
Nike's real giving the extra option but
like once he once he played King D1 I
was pretty confident that I was winning
here
um but when you play Knight G3 that's
like a cold shower yeah like yeah smokes
you're actually losing now yeah yeah no
I it's crazy I I like and the thing is
like this has happened to me so many
times before too like when I when I let
go of the piece I was like okay this is
just another Moment Like This is gonna
happen to me like I don't know what I
can do about this like it just sort of
was trying in that minute just to sit
there and not like make any faces so I
was just trying to like Zoom my brain
out because I I'm a very expressive
person so I figured like if I was
thinking about the fact that I've
blundered I would probably
subconsciously make a face or something
so I'm just trying to zone out for the
whole minute and like not think about it
too much
and it paid off congratulations it did
I want to say Well done but instead I
just say good luck with the rest of the
term thank you nice nice but the Rook
sacrifice